la scelta tra essere o non essere
sostenibili in realtà non esiste più
anche perché se ci pensate è sostenibile
colpire durevole cioè essere
insostenibili vuol dire finire
l'azienda è insostenibile se fallisce la
famiglia la società insostenibile se a
un certo punto collassa quindi la
sostenibilità eco che stava anche ha
detto come tipologia proprio i francesi
l'hanno tradotta meglio dei born to run
che noi sostenibile non sappiamo bene
cosa vuol dire invece di lettura re nel
tempo quindi non esiste l'opzione non
voglio durare
detto ciò però quello che va anche
spiegato che ci sono un sacco di scelte
da dover fare a valle e quindi essere
sostenibile non è il problema
cosa vuol dire essere sostenibili è il
problema e ne avete citati diversi prima
cioè ci sono un sacco di situazioni
controverse la scelta lettera essere
buoni essere cattivi sono tanti modi per
essere buoni faccio proprio più
il più il più banale il cioè c'è molto
interesse anche le aziende ci spingono
consumi ai prodotti cento per cento
italiani o chilometro zero è più
sostenibile
alcune volte sia alcune volte no quando
io avevo l'età dei ragazzi che adesso
stanno all'università si parlava di per
esempio consuma equo e solidale era
sostenibile importare il cibo dai paesi
più poveri
oggi consegniamo sostenibile prendere il
cibo dei contadini italiani non voglio
dire sia giusto o sbagliato è una scelta
è quello che io vorrei dire che sono
tante scelte molto difficili dire
consumatori fate qualcosa impegnatevi ma
su cosa prima dicevi lavate la macchina
ma consumate poca acqua ma tremonti non
lavata nella macchina vi rendete conto
che i nostri nipoti tirano voi la
parlata e la macchina con l'acqua
potabile che noi non abbiamo più lavate
il bagno con l'acqua potabile facevate
delle cose con l'acqua può tacere
esistono delle situazioni a volte
piccole tipo lavarono lavare la macchina
oa vero non aver la macchina un accordo
con te penso non abbiamo la ma non
l'avevamo non usiamo la macchina o nulla
utilizziamo più sono delle scelte
importantissime difficile che non
possiamo lasciare alle aziende e nepi
dai cittadini alle aziende perché
chiaramente le voltano a proprio
vantaggio
a proposito di acqua ci sono aziende che
in genere non vengono consigliate super
sostenibili che producono bevande
gassate non voglio
citare il nome ma insomma la più
importante al mondo quando parla di
sostenibilità cosa dice noi consumiamo
poca acqua una bottiglia di quella
bevanda beh si può dire coca cola
equivale a circa un litro e mezzo di
acqua quindi un litro di qualcosa un
litro e mezzo di acqua una bottiglia di
brunello di montalcino un libro di
bonello non so 50 litri d'acqua forse
per realizzarlo se l'acqua è la priorità
non bisogna più bere il vino e
soprattutto il vino di qualità meglio
bere qualcosa o addirittura l'acqua anzi
meglio l'acqua del rubinetto
capite che sono scelte che hanno un
impatto fortissimo sulle imprese hanno
impatto fortissimo sull'economia chi è
che deve decidere
lasciamo alle aziende no perché diranno
gli ho scelto la cosa giusta perché ho
ridotto l'acqua altre aziende magari con
il tolto la plastica e quella è una cosa
importante era togliere la plastica stai
facendo sfaceli pensate si citava le
aziende energetiche e l'eni si presenta
come un azienda sostenibile il cut
economia circolare magari fa anche delle
cose bellissime
non lo metto in dubbio ma non può essere
lei a dire non usiamo più petrolio o non
usiamo più le automobili per spostarci
quindi c'è un livello un po più alto e
questo livello alto secondo me ancora
non c'è perché sarebbe il polimero della
politica il ramo della politica che
dovrebbe dire ok abbiamo deciso adesso
dentro roma le macchine non ci sono più
punto ci saranno due anni d'inferno un
anno d'inferno falliranno tutti i negozi
di turisti un altro purtroppo queste
scelte hanno dei danni perché dico sono
scelte difficili perché non sono scelte
tra il bene e il male
sono scelte tra chi guadagna e chi perde
qualcuno perderà perché anche se non
compriamo più automobili qualcuno va a
casa senza stipendio siamo d'accordo
scelte difficilissime
se noi vogliamo essere come famiglia i
più sostenibili possibili prima che
potremo fare non avere figli perché
chiaramente la cosa più impattante è una
scelta morale una scelta difficilissima
nessuno stato può dire alle famiglie non
fate figli che qualcuno ci ha provato ma
insomma sono veramente difficile quindi
qual è la mia conclusione conclusione
che dobbiamo un pochino alzare il
livello cioè da un lato mantenere il
livello al sì risparmiamo
non buttiamo il cibo facciamo tutte cose
utili che alcune sono di buon senso
tenete presente che anche se il 30 per
cento di cibo buttato non si butta più
c'è il 30 per cento in meno di fatturato
nell'azienda alimentare io sarei
d'accordo che ci fosse però qualcuno
perderà soldi ecco vorrei che alzassero
un po il livello che riportassimo sulla
politica delle scelte che sono scelte di
valore quindi sono scelte morali etiche
non so come definirlo un tempo le scelte
le facevano perchè quando era un
militare c'era scritto dio patria
famiglia ciano dei valori c'era una
gerarchia adesso non abbiamo più questa
gerarchia occorre che qualcuno ce l'ha
riproponga magari anche portando il
dibattito politico su questi livelli
alti forse arriveremo a parlare di
filosofia può essere però il mio pro la
mia preoccupazione è che se si fanno
tante cose ognuno la interpreta a modo
suo il risultato complessivo potrebbe
essere un po deludente su certi aspetti
proprio perché in realtà tutti possono
dire gli ho fatto il mio io ho un
allevamento e sono un pochino più
sostenibile perché le galline invece di
metterle in gabbia l'ho messa a terra
parte che questa è una cosa strana ma se
stanno a terra la cintura è maggiore che
se stanno in gabbia però puntato al
benessere animale benissimo era quella
la cosa più importante o forse dovremmo
a mangiar meno pollo forse andare un po
più mangiare la carne su questo vorrei
un po interrogarmi e credo che ci sta ai
vertici dovrebbe sapere che deve dare
degli indirizzi e questi indirizzi
dipenderanno delle riflessioni che in
parte le potarla scienza ma la scienza
ti dalle misure ma non ti da le scelte
perché poi che sia più importante la
carbon footprint la water footprint o
che sia più importante fare l'eolico o
addirittura a ridurre invece
completamente il consumo di energia
quelle purtroppo sono scelte che sono
scelte politiche e la politica fa un po
richiamata in causa su questo